charter school is becoming a lot more
popular in the valley Victoria Saha
explains why more parents and students
are opting for this type of education
she reports on a new all-girls school on
Mojave near Desert Inn
Clark County home to 70 Charter Schools
funded by this state just like any
public school why Charter Schools it's
just a nice option especially if you
have a student who's struggling to fit
in in a general Ed situation or the
class Rises are too big a bit more time
to get our social studies teacher Nadia
ramnath is no stranger to charter
schools in her 10 years of teaching or
you feel like they're lost in the system
a charter school is a great place for
them to really focus in on who they are
what they want to do but it's her first
time teaching at a single sex Charter
School such as a young woman's
Leadership Academy located in east Las
Vegas it's Nevada's first all-girls
Public Charter School for 6th through
12th grade families appreciate having an
opportunity for choice that they want
what's best for their Scholars principal
Whitney McIntosh says they're able to be
flexible in the curriculum such as
taking a day to explore career options
even at a young age they get to see it
there's so many things out there that
they didn't know existed besides their
regular syllabus the students here at
the Young Women's Leadership Academy are
taught to speak out many students
finding the confidence in themselves to
raise their hand in class for the very
first time
the dynamic here is definitely building
a community of strong women I honestly
really love it because it's really build
up my confidence ever since I've came
here that's because students like
Brianna Williams aren't struggling to be
noticed by teachers they already are we
are trying to instill responsibility in
these young women and the opportunity to
be leaders not just you know at a job
but within their own community in their
households another advantage of smaller
class sizes offered by Charter Schools
Victoria 8 News Now